But great music you feel it. It gets
into you. It gets into your cells you
know very primal. It is the language of
the spirit. There is worship involved
whether it's God, nature, money, a
extraordinary woman has just walked
across the street. But it seems to be
that music is where we are creatures of
uh
awe. So what or who then does Bono
worship? I think it's the it's a
defining question for a Christian is who
was Christ crucified because he said he
was the son of God. So he either in my
view was the son of God or he was not no
no no nuts nuts. Forget rock and roll
messianic complexes. This is like I mean
Charlie Manson type delirium. And I find
it hard to accept
that all the millions and millions of
lives, half the earth for 2,000 years
have been touched, have felt their lives
touched and inspired
by some nutter. I just I don't believe
it. I So therefore, it follows that you
believe he was divine. Yes. And
therefore, it follows that you believe
that he rose physically from the dead.
Yes. Yeah. I'm into I have no problem
with miracles. This was a couple of
years back. He said the same thing to
Joe Rogan just a couple of days ago. As
a believer, I don't know if you know, I
am a believer. I'm I'm just not a very
good one. A quick Google search will
show that many YouTube band members also
believe in Jesus. Though at times their
faith can seem complicated.
exist.
Jesus, Jew, Muhammad, it's true. All
sons
of Abraham.
Father
Abraham
will
angel
of the devil.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Did you two and Bono deny their belief
in Jesus and I still haven't found what
I'm looking for? What about wake up dead
man? It starts off with what seems to be
a sincere cry to Jesus for help. Wake
up.
Wake up dead man.
Jesus,
I'm waiting here.
I know you're looking out for us. But
then the song takes a turn. Maybe the
hands are freeus.
We just around the corner.
[Music]
Did you think to try and warn her?
Were you working on something new?
The same goes for their song. For the
first time, it's a love song, yet
suddenly it includes lyrics that seem
oddly spiritual and really out of
context.
My father is a rich man.
He wears a rich man's cloak.
[Music]
gave me the keys to his kingdom coming.
Give me a cup of gold.
[Music]
He said, "I have been legends
and there are many rooms to see.
I live by the back door
and I throw away
throw away."
[Music]
Okay. So, what about angels? Those
appear in YouTube's song as well. If God
will send his angels
and if God will send a sign
and if God will send his angels, will
everything be all right?
[Music]
Fall off of her face.
Would he even take back if he could?
[Music]
But here's the question. If God sends
his angels, where should they lead us?
To the feet of Jesus. Throughout
scripture, whenever God sent angels, it
was to bring comfort, guidance, or
warning to his people. And Jesus himself
promised in Hebrews 13:5, "I will never
leave you nor forsake you." So, who is
Jesus really? A myth? a historical
figure, the son of God, God himself.
According to historical and
archaeological evidence, he did walk the
earth 2,000 years ago. But is this who
he claimed to be? Did he really rise
from the dead? To explore that question
or not is a decision you have to make or
leave it forever unanswered. But if you
are willing to start that journey, I
recommend starting with the Bible. You
can never go wrong there.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos. And drop
a comments below, and we'll try to get
back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.